في تحقيق من خان يونس لفتت الول ستريت
جورنال الى ان القوات الاسرائيليه في جنوب
قطاع غزه تتجه نحو مازق ورات الصحيفه ان
محاوله السيطره على ما سمتها متاهات انفاق
خان يونس ستكون مغامره محفوفه بالمخاطر
لانها تعني تضييق الخناق على اعداد هائله
من الفلسطينيين النازحين اصلا وتتزامن مع
تصاعد الاحتجاجات الدوليه بسبب العدد
الكبير من القتلى والجرحى بين المدنيين
الفلسطينيين الضغوط على اسرائيل لتغيير
تكتيكاتها قالت صحيفه الجارديان ان مسؤولي
الاغاثه في غزه يعتقدون بوجود جيوب مجاعه
في القطاع لافتين الى ان الاباء اصبحوا
يضحون بنصيبهم من الطعام لصالح اطفالهم
وتحدث اطباء عن اطفال اضعفهم نقص الغذاء
وتوفوا بسبب انخفاض حراره الجسم واضافوا
ان العديد من الاطفال حديثي الولاده الذين
عانت امهاتهم من سوء التغذيه لم يصمدوا في
الحياه الا لبضعه ايام راى الكاتب دانييل
جولدمان في صحيفه جورسليم بوست ان اسرائيل
بحاجه الى رؤيه سياسيه وسطيه جديده واضاف
ان مناخ الوحده الحاليه نجح في تغطيه
الشروخ السياسيه والاجتماعيه التي تغلي
تحت السطح لكن خلافات ما قبل السابع من
اكتوبر قد تعود الى الظهور بسهوله واذا
حدث ذلك فان التعافي سيكون اكثر صعوبه
طالبت افتتاحيه ها ارتس بالتخلص من
نتنياهو قبل ان تنفجر الضفه الغربيه وقالت
ان التصعيد في الضفه وفتح جبهه اخرى في
الحرب خطر يجب منعه واشارت الصحيفه الى ان
حكومه نتنياهو لا تفعل سوى صب الزيت على
النار بهجمات اللفظيه على السلطه
الفلسطينيه وبمقارنة
عبر باب المندب اصبحت تضطر للاعلان عن عدم
وجود اي صله لها باسرائيل وتدخل ذلك ضمن
بياناتها الملاحيه وقالت الصحيفه ان طواقم
البواخر تفعل ذلك استجابه لشرط الحوثيين
حتى تنجو من الخطر وتتفادى ممرا بحريا
طويلا يلتف حول القاره الافريقيه قال
ديفيد اجناش في الواشنطن بوست ان الحوثيين
يملكون ما يمكن تسميتها بقوه عنق الزجاجه
فهم يسيطرون على ممر باب المندب ما يتيح
لهم التاثير في سلاسل التوريد العالميه
وتشكل هذه القدره نقطه ضعف بالغه الاهميه
في الاقتصاد العالمي ورغم ذلك لا تنال
نصيبها من النقاش وهي نقطه ضعف تبدو
الولايات المتحده التي تتباهى بدورها
كضامن لحريه الملاحه عاجزه عن منعها راى
مقال في مجله فورين افيرز ان حرب غزه احيت
محور المقاومه في الشرق الاوسط محذرا من
ان العداء للغرب قد يشعل شراره التطرف
والاضطرابات السياسيه مجددا وقال ان بيل
الوحيد لابعاد هذا الخطر يكمن في انهاء
الحرب بغزه والتفاوض على تسويه حقيقيه
وعادله للصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني